las causas para que estos 18 pueblos
indígenas se encuentren en riesgo de
desaparecer tienen que ver con el cambio
climático con la contaminación de los
ríos por efectos de la minería artesanal
y también con los desplazamientos
humanos les pongo algunos ejemplos en el
caso de oruro un pueblo indígena llamado
los urumuratos se ha quedado sin su
medio de vida porque el lago popó del
que ellos vivían pescando prácticamente
se ha secado ellos ahora han tenido que
migrar o directamente están
Sobreviviendo en esa región por otro
lado por ejemplo en la amazonía
boliviana están los sejas que según un
último estudio presentan altísimos
niveles de mercurio en su organismo
producto de la minería artesanal del Oro
que utiliza esa sustancia para extraer
el mineral de las aguas y por otro lado
en el Oriente del país también existen
muchos pueblos el riesgo por los
desplazamientos humanos por ejemplo los
ayoreos que están constantemente
hacediados por los grupos campesi los
que toman ilegalmente sus tierras y les
obligan a migrar a otras regiones del
país el riesgo como ustedes pueden ver
es demasiado alto y por eso el gobierno
ha decidido emitir un decreto supremo y
crear un comité para atender esta
situación este comité está conformado
por cinco ministerios y hará un
diagnóstico de la situación para tratar
de atender esta situación de riesgo de
los pueblos indígenas en Bolivia Mary y
cambiamos de tema cuéntenos qué ha
ocurrido con los incendios forestales en
los yungas en la paz que han afectado a
nueve mil personas y hacen parte de las
más de 300.000 hectáreas incendiadas
este año en el país
estos incendios lamentablemente no se
han podido controlar todavía sin embargo
ha habido una reducción importante en
concreto en las provincias de los yungas
los focos de calor han bajado de 29 a
diez en las últimas horas sin embargo
las afectaciones son muy grandes
particularmente a estas familias que
señalabas pero también a los cultivos
cultivos de cítricos coca tradicional
café e incluso la red eléctrica han sido
afectados por estos incendios a nivel
nacional se han reportado cuatro mil
focos de calor y en las últimas horas el
reporte y el registro indica que esos
focos han reducido a más de 300 este
problema está asociado también al de la
sequía el gobierno ha informado que más
de cien mil familias están siendo
afectadas a nivel nacional por efectos
de este fenómeno climático